joy is a great teacher who has created
many amazing courses
and written a bunch of helpful technical
articles in this course he will teach
you how async
await and promises work in javascript
hey guys joy here in this video we're
gonna make ice cream and learn
asynchronous javascript
yes you heard me right we're gonna make
ice cream today and along the way we're
gonna discuss three topics
callbacks promises async await along
with
examples the video will go like this
over here we're gonna make the main
project
which is the ice cream project and over
here we're gonna look at some
examples so that you can better
understand how the system works
but the first question is what is
asynchronous javascript and why should
you even care
if you want to make bigger projects more
efficiently than this is for you
what asynchronous javascript does is it
allows you to break down bigger projects
into smaller tasks
and then using any of these three
methods over here either callbacks
promises or async await
what you can do is you can form a
connection between these small steps
in a way that you can get the final
result so here's an example of what i
mean
so this is the ice cream that we're
gonna make today here is the ice cream
okay
so using asynchronous javascript we can
break it down into smaller steps
if we do that it looks something like
this you can see that these are the
seven steps to make ice cream first
starting with the place order then we're
gonna
cut the fruits then we're gonna add
water and ice so on and so
forth and at the very last we're gonna
serve ice cream
to make you understand this topic even
better i have added some time function
as well
you can see this over here it takes two
seconds to place the order
two seconds to cut the fruit one second
to add water and ice
so on and so forth and at the very last
we're gonna serve ice cream
take the money and buy ourselves a lambo
because why not
if you want to learn asynchronous
javascript better you need to know the
difference between two things
synchronous and asynchronous system
let's start discussing with the
synchronous system
let me explain this to you in clear
words let's say that i have given you 10
tasks
and just one hand 10 task one hand
so how will you do the task you're gonna
do one by one right
like this look one two
three so we are in tax number three
right you cannot jump to the tax number
seven
unless you do four five six
and then seven right so what are you
doing you are doing one by one right
but in the asynchronous system for ten
tasks
you will be given ten hands so that you
can work independently without depending
on
anyone look at this image over here
this is the synchronous system they are
loading one by one
the second image doesn't load unless the
first one does
and the third image doesn't load unless
the second one does which means that
they're
following a order like this one two
three and on the asynchronous way you
can see that nobody depends on anyone
they are loading on their own pace
independently by the way i wrote an
entire article on the topic that we're
gonna discuss today so that you can
understand it better
at the same time you can revise it from
here more easily efficiently and quickly
link of this article will be given in
the description down below go and check
it out
to summarize let's say that we are
setting up a marathon for three persons
how many person
three person if you are doing it in the
synchronous way what will happen is you
just have
one single lane and you have to place
those three persons
on this single lane in the serial of one
two three and the rule is nobody can
overtake the other everyone has to
finish the race one by one
look at this image over here this is the
synchronous system
this is the finish line over here okay
and the images
which is the persons one two and three
are standing
on the same lane which lane same lane
and nobody can overtake the other
everyone has to finish the race
one by one so the person three or the
image 3
will finish the race first then the
second one and the first one
like this the single lane the
synchronous system
if anyone stops the entire process stops
if the image 3 stops over here then
everyone has to stop
and if we are setting the marathon in an
asynchronous way
for three persons we will have three
lanes if we have more participants then
the number of
lanes will also increase which means
that nobody stops for anyone they can
finish the race
independently on their own pace if
anyone stops
then the system still continues to run
look at this image over here
this is the finish line and this is the
participants over here and these are the
lanes okay
lane number one two and three the image
one
two and three they're gonna finish the
race on their own pace
i hope you understand the difference
between the synchronous and the
asynchronous system
let's look at some examples right now
you can use any code editor you want but
for this tutorial i'm going to write it
on codepen because it has a simple
interface so you can follow along with
me if you want
so open codepen dot io and then you
click this pen over here
then you're gonna click this small pen
icon over here and you're gonna name
this project anything you want i'm gonna
write it async js
[Music]
okay and then you save it ctrl s
like this ctrl s and now you're gonna
drag it at the middle
like this and double click on the
javascript section like this and it's
gonna expand
and in order to open the console you're
gonna click the small
icon over here you can see that like
this
double click on here and it's gonna
expand like this
we need to know we need to do one more
setting you come over here this small
gear icon over here click it
click on behavior and you enable
everything except this one
the auto updating preview okay turn it
off
save and close and then we're gonna
manually get a run button over here
why is that that's because every time we
write a single letter
corporal runs it automatically which
means that
every time we write a single letter
we're gonna get an error
after error after error in order to
avoid that i have turned off this
setting
every time we finish writing our code we
can manually run
it like this okay now let's look at the
synchronous system example
so over here you write synchronous
s-y-m-c-h-r-o-n-o-u-s
synchronous like this and you comment
this like this
and over here we're gonna write
console.log
five times how many times five times
like this follow me
console.log okay brackets
double quotes space over here okay you
copy this
ctrl c and then ctrl v
five times okay three four five
keep some gap over here as well
additional gaps
um like this all right so over here
we're gonna write
a full sentence okay i eat ice cream
with a spoon so we can divide it by
phrases okay then follow me along i
eat ice cream
width oh sorry a
spoon okay ctrl s to save it and then
you're gonna click this run over here
and then we're gonna get the result
there we go you can see that
our phrases are printed one by one
serially that's because javascript runs
from the top to the bottom
how does javascript run from the top to
the bottom
serially in this process if anyone gets
stuck
then the entire process gets stuck this
is the
synchronous system if you change the
cereal
let's say that i want to change the
spoon from here to here okay
control x and then you paste it over
here control v
control s you clear this console over
here
and then you run it again let's see what
let's see the result
now you can see that i eat spoon ice
cream with
a you see that javascript doesn't care
about anything
it's gonna run the code from the top to
the bottom
this is what the synchronous system now
let's look at the asynchronous system
now over here right asynchronous okay a
synchronous done clear the console over
here
you change the serial control x okay
and over here ctrl c ctrl
s and now come over here at the bottom i
need to make you understand
a small function named set timeout
function which is a built-in function of
javascript what this does is it
allows you to run a function after a
specific amount
of time so you write set timeout
set then capital letter t time out
this one okay then brackets
the first thing that we are gonna pass
as an argument is a
function so we're going to use the arrow
function don't worry i'm going to
explain arrow function
and the regular function we write the
arrow function like this
okay equal to then this side curly
braces
now let's look at the difference between
function the regular one and the
arrow function okay in the regular way
we write a function
like this first the function keyword
okay then we're gonna name it like this
a b c d e f g however you like
right then you put that then you put
that bracket like this okay
and then curly braces this is the
regular function
but in the error function how we write
it is
we're gonna write either let var or
const
okay like this and then we're gonna put
the name over here
what was the name of this function
abcded right
so we're gonna write a b c d e d which
is the name of that function
like this
like this and then equal to and then
we're gonna put
brackets over here and then this sign
over here the arrow side
and then curly braces on the regular
function we used to put
our arguments on this bracket like a
b c d etc
in the arrow function we place our
arguments over here a
b sorry b c
d etcetera i hope you understood the
difference between two
for this project i'm going to use the
arrow function okay
the latter one this one so once we have
entered the function
inside the set timeout as an
argument the next thing that we're going
to put is the time okay
so it is actually counted as
milliseconds if we write
1000 it's gonna count as millisecond
which means
one second so if we write let's say 3000
it means 3000 milliseconds which means
three seconds okay
now come over here let's say that i want
to
cut this and place it inside the set
timeout function
how will you do it we'll cut it like
this ctrl
x and then inside over here this curly
braces we're going to place it over here
okay ctrl
v and now let's change it to four
seconds by the way set timeout is a
asynchronous function okay you cut this
from here ctrl
x and you paste it over here ctrl
v like this ctrl s to save it and then
we're gonna
press this run function but before that
do you remember what i told you
javascript runs from the top to the
bottom how
from the top to the bottom and let's see
how this works okay
you run it like this and let's see the
result
now you can see that we have got i eat
with a spoon and then after how many
seconds after
four seconds we got the ice cream over
here
now how does this system work this is
the asynchronous system okay
asynchronous system look the cereal is
over here okay
i eat ice cream with a spoon the sale is
over here as well you can see that i eat
ice cream with a
spoon the system is actually working
like this look
i eat and then this ice cream over here
it has a set time or function which
means that
we're gonna have another hand over here
it's gonna take
this function at the side which is our
second lane okay
this is our main lane i mean main
road this is the secondary road it is
taking that asynchronous call
at this hand and after four seconds it's
gonna release it on our main lane
like this until then what will happen
look i
eat ice cream is the asynchronous call
which means that it's gonna take it over
here
after four seconds is gonna get released
then with a spoon after four seconds
it's gonna come over here so this is how
the asynchronous system works i hope you
understood it
now we're gonna start our discussion
with callbacks
but before that if you are new to the
channel feel free to subscribe because i
post videos based on practical website
projects
so that you can level up your coding
skills if that sounds interesting hit
the subscribe button and join my gang
and without further ado
let's get started let's talk about
callbacks what
are they in simple terms very simple
terms
calling a function inside another
function is called a callback
in even more simple terms what it does
is it forms
connection between what functions
let's look at one example with callbacks
and then we're gonna start our ice cream
business
okay now back to codepen you delete
everything okay control a then
delete okay you cleared the console over
here as well
control s okay so what did i tell you
before
callbacks means calling a function
inside another function so we will
create two functions to form that
relationship what relationship okay
function one function two like this
function
one okay we're gonna use the regular
function
nothing complicated no politics here
okay function
two okay now inside function one what
we're gonna write is
console.log okay console.log
over here we're gonna write function one
or let's write step one okay step
one oh sorry like this step one and
inside over here we're gonna write
console.log
step two
like this in order to run this function
what do we do we write
the name of the function at the bottom
like this look
we call it like this one then brackets
over here ctrl
s you run this button over here after
you clear the console okay
run it like this and we're gonna see
step one on the console
let's wait ah there we go this is step
one okay
and how do we call the function two in
the same process we write it over here
i mean we call it over here like this
okay control
s don't forget to clear the console over
here clear it like this and then you
press this run button
now you can see that we have step one
step two
that's because we have an order right
javascript runs from the top to the
bottom
look which one is first one is first and
then
two but if we reverse the order
if i write two first and then one like
this ctrl
x ctrl v like this so first is two and
then one
so what will happen two will run first
and then
one clear the console save it
run it you can see that we have step two
first and then step one
these are regular functions now let's
form a relationship between these two
using a callback what a callback okay
let's remove this okay now we're going
to make a connection of function 2
inside function1 so how do we do it we
do it
using a argument we're going to write
over here
call 2 c a double l hyphen okay
two this is nothing this is just an
argument okay
nothing else and over here we're gonna
write step one
complete okay this is nothing special
this is just gonna get printed on our
console okay
please call step
two like this okay oh
like this now in order to provoke
function two what we do is we take this
argument over here call 2
and then as number 2 function is a
function what we're going to write is
we're going to give
brackets over here like this and now
it's gonna call it
every time once our console.log is
printed
like this look we don't have to call 2
anymore we just call
1 1 and then inside over here we're
going to pass
function number two which one function
number two okay
two like this look how did i form a
relationship between these two
if you clear the console save it run it
let's see the result
look what is happening step one complete
please call
step two and then we have the step two
if you remember javascript runs from the
top to the bottom right
so our console.log is at the first and
then
call two but if you reverse the order
what will happen let's see
control x okay call it over here control
v
control s okay and now clear the console
run it and let's see what happens now
you can see that step two is first and
then step one complete
place called step two don't worry about
this if you don't understand it we're
gonna look at another example right now
for that we're gonna start our ice cream
business right now
for that we need to know the
relationship between our customers
and us you can see that this is the flow
okay first we get the order from the
customers
then we're gonna fetch the ingredients
then we're gonna start the production
and then we're gonna serve
ice cream okay so we're gonna create two
functions how many functions
two functions order function production
function okay
if we don't get the order we cannot
start the production
this is how we are forming a connection
between these two functions using what
tell me using a callback come on let's
go to codepen and
see the example come over to codepen
over here you delete everything
okay we're going to use arrow function
what function
arrow function right let first is order
because
without the order the production doesn't
start okay order
equal to brackets then
arrow sign curly braces like this okay
now write the production function but
before that clear this console
okay uh let production
production here we're gonna make the ice
cream okay
so once we get the order we're gonna
start the production of our ice cream
okay
production equal to brackets
error sign curly braces like this okay
now in order to form that connection
that every time we get the order
the production will start we do it like
this okay
you come over here okay you pass an
argument
we're gonna name it call production okay
call
underscore production okay
and inside this curly braces we're gonna
write the same thing okay the exact same
name ctrl c
ctrl v over here and then brackets okay
brackets like this and look at there
we have formed a relationship between
these two functions using what a
callback
now let's test it now we're gonna write
console.log
console.log okay
order placed
please call production
like this okay and inside over here
we're gonna write console.log
console.log
order received
starting production
like this okay now in order to run our
function what we'll do is
we're gonna write order over here or
there
and inside that order we're gonna write
the production
we're gonna pass this function over here
inside here okay
production like this okay so ctrl s
clear the console save it run it let's
see what happens
now you can see that we have order
placed
please call production and then we got
order
received start production i hope you
understand how the system works
forming relationship between functions
using a callback
now let's understand one more thing
relationship between the front end
and the back end the front end is our
kitchen where we will make the ice cream
and the back end is where we will store
ingredients like
fruits liquid stuffs machineries
raw materials chocolate
etc you know what raw materials means
right the stocks our stocks
so the stocks is the back end kitchen is
the front end okay
so we're gonna store our stocks inside a
variable okay so come over to codepen
over here at the very top okay you keep
some space over here
and we're gonna write let okay let
stocks
so this variable will hold all of our
stocks like fruits
liquids holders toppings like chocolate
peanuts etc okay and that equal to we're
gonna create a
object over here like this object okay
and inside that object
we're gonna write arrays like this look
f-r-u-i-t-s okay then colon over here
we're gonna store all our fruits
inside what an array okay like this
then we're gonna write the name of our
fruits as i have defined them over here
i'm gonna copy it over here
okay ctrl c and then
ctrl v over here now pause the video
take a moment to write these fruits okay
now how do we access a single stock
from this variable okay we comment
everything from here from the top to
bottom like this
comment this like this and in order to
select
one stock we will do it like this first
of all we write the name of the
variable what is the name of the
variable stocks okay
s-t-o-c-k-s then dot y dot because it is
an
object in order to access the object we
need to form a dot
and then the name of the object is which
is fruits okay
capital letter f r u i t s
and then what is this this is an array
so how does the array works is
it is arranged in the order of zero
one two and three okay so in order to
access that you write square bracket
okay and then if you want to access the
banana
let's look at the order zero one two we
write two over here
okay and now let's print on the console
in order to do that we write
console.log then brackets
at the end bracket close it ctrl
s clear it and then run it
look we got the banana in the same way
we have more
stocks we have the holders the cups cone
sticks
and the toppings as chocolate sprinkles
so this is the variable that i have
created okay i'm gonna copy it from here
ctrl c and then over here i'm gonna
paste it ctrl v
now pause the video take a moment and
write these talks on your code editor
so once that's done you clear this from
here
okay clear the console and you bring
all of this back okay like this there we
go
okay now we're gonna clean our console
from here remove this and we're gonna
remove this okay
and keep everything else and then you
comment this
from here okay now now the first thing
is
the order right customer places the
order the order is
changeable which means how many options
do we have look at our menu we have the
strawberry
grapes banana and apple which means that
the customer
can pick anything he wishes which means
that for this we need a variable
so over here we're gonna write fruit
name
f-r-u-i-t okay underscore
and a-m-e like this then place coma over
here
so we have two arguments the fruit name
and the call production
the customer picks the fruit it gets
over here
and then we get to know that what the
customer picked
and then we're gonna start the
production this is how we are forming a
relationship between our functions
okay and over here you uncomment this
and we need to keep it blank for now
okay you give double quotes over here
then comma okay you control s
if you remember this is our steps along
with the time
so in order to ensure the time function
we're gonna use settimeout
and we're gonna print the steps on our
console okay so follow along with me
first of all we're gonna place the order
by picking a fruit name okay
come back to vs code over here and
and in order to select the fruit and
place the order it takes two seconds how
many seconds
two seconds so come back to vs code over
here and inside this
order function okay come
here and write console or before writing
console.log you have to use a set
timeout function because it takes how
many seconds
two seconds set timeout like this
and inside over here we're going to use
a arrow function you can also use an
anonymous function
like this look function bracket
curly braces like this but we're gonna
keep it simple
we remove this remove this function from
here
and you're gonna give that arrow sign
like this okay
and at the end we're gonna place the
time function okay how many seconds
two seconds so we're gonna write two
thousand milliseconds okay two
one two three like this and inside over
here we're gonna write
console.log because we're gonna
because we're gonna print the result on
our console okay
and use a backtick we are not gonna use
double quote
no no no we're not using double quotes
we're gonna use a backtick
what backtick if you want to access the
backtick
look at my keyboard over here this is
the exit key
and this is the key to write backticks
okay so you
click this just once and it's going to
print us to backticks like this
now we're going to pass this fruit name
inside this console.log
so how do we do this first of all we're
gonna write a dollar sign okay
what a dollar sign dollar sign and then
curly braces like this
and then we're gonna place this inside
here but before that we need to write
something we need to write the stocks
okay
that's because we are picking it from
our stocks right so stocks
then the name of our um fruits okay
so dot u i t s and then what
square brackets right square brackets
over here and then we're gonna pass this
inside there okay control c control c
and then right ctrl v over here okay
now we're gonna save it let me show you
how the system works okay
so over here um we're gonna write
zero control s clear the console
run it let's see what do we get on the
result
we got strawberry you can see that the
first fruit on our stocks is a
strawberry right i explained this to you
right if you can recall
how to access the stocks we do it like
this
stocks dot f-r-u-i-t-s
then square brackets and then the name
of our fruit
i mean the order of i mean the order of
the fruit
0 1 2 3 right so i have placed this
inside over here and then inside the
array i have
placed this and over here i have placed
zero which means that this
zero is coming over here which
eventually means that we're going to get
the strawberry i hope
you understood this nothing complicated
okay
stocks dot fruits then this
and over here you write was selected
like this then ctrl f clear the console
run it and let's see what we get
strawberry was selected you can see that
you can notice that we got the result
after two seconds
why is that that's because we are using
a set timeout function over here
which takes two seconds i mean it i mean
it prints our result after two seconds
okay let's start writing inside our
production function okay
so come over here we're gonna use
another set time of function which
runs in zero seconds how do we do it we
do it like this
right set timeout bracket
and pass a function over here like this
arrow function okay
and then it's gonna run in zero seconds
how many seconds zero seconds so right
zero
zero zero zero inside over here we're
gonna write console.log
and right production has started and
that's because we got the order right
production has
started ctrl s
clear the console let's run it so we're
gonna
get the result after two seconds one two
there we go we have the production has
started and then strawberry was
selected now we are seeing a odd
behavior over here why is that
we were supposed to get this one first
and the production has started at the
last
that's because if you focus over here
you can see that
look at the order okay javascript runs
from the top to the bottom okay
so it is saying that this is a set timer
function which means that it's gonna
take two seconds and this one
this is gonna take how many seconds zero
seconds okay so this one
will be stopped this is over here and
this call production will start
immediately so this is
the call production which is production
has started over here
and strawberry was selected this is over
here that's why we are getting this
order
but if you want to fix that what you
have to do is you're going to cut it
from here
control x and you're going to place it
where inside that set them out function
okay like this look ctrl v over here
okay
now what will happen is it's not going
to start
the production unless the foot was
selected
now let's save it clear the console and
run it and let's see what happens
one two so you can see that after two
seconds
strawberry was selected and immediately
we got the result production has started
that's because we have set two seconds
for which one strawberry was selected
and zero seconds for which one
production has started like this i hope
you understood so far now let's look at
our second step which is
um we're gonna cut the fruit and it will
take two seconds
so come inside the production function
we are done with our
order function okay you can minimize it
like this we don't need it anymore
and don't make that mistake again
otherwise you're gonna get the reverse
order
which we watched previously which is we
got the production first
and the strawberry at the last don't
write it outside okay
don't write it over here you're gonna
write it inside this set timeout
function okay
so you come over here and we're gonna
write another set timeout okay it's
gonna be two seconds how many
two seconds set timeout okay
brackets and then pass a arrow function
like this
okay arrow sign curly braces and then
the time function okay how many seconds
two seconds two one two three like this
and inside over here we're gonna write
the fruit has been chopped console
the log the
has been chopped ctrl
s let's clear the console save it
let's run it and see what happens one
two
again one two
so we're getting the strawberry after
two seconds
we have got the production immediately
and then we have got the fruit has been
chopped after
another additional two seconds now our
system is running perfectly fine
now let's follow the steps and complete
our ice cream production
so that we can buy ourselves a lambo
because why not
now the third step is to add water and
ice and it takes one second how many
one seconds so inside the production
function where will we write
we're going to write it inside this set
timeout function so this is the parent
children it will be the grandchildren
okay so the fruit has been chopped over
here
enter to give some spacings and we're
going to write
set timeout like this okay brackets
then pass the arrow function like this
equal to
okay curly braces don't worry i know
where we're going
we are going to a callback hell this is
called a callback hell and i'm coming to
the point don't worry don't
don't panic okay and over here you write
the time function okay
1000 seconds over here like this okay
and inside over here
console.log like this
okay inside over here we're not gonna
write
double quotes we're gonna write
backticks that's because we have to add
water and
ice and the water and ice is inside our
stocks over here which is the liquid
and then water ice zero and one in order
to pick them
pay close attention to what i write over
here okay don't focus on anything else
one two three this is the third step
okay
inside over here back ticks what
backticks like this
dollar sign and then curly braces okay
curly braces like this and you write end
over here okay and then curly braces
again like this
along with the dollar sign okay you're
gonna
you're gonna write was added
so if you translate it sounds like this
dash and dash was added so we're gonna
write
so we're gonna pick the water and ice so
first of all we're gonna write
stocks okay stocks
dot liquid okay as because it is the
name of that
object liquid and then
square brackets like this over here
you're gonna write
zero okay that's because it will select
the water
the first thing is the water and then we
have the ice
in order to pick that ice over here okay
we're gonna write
stocks dot liquid
okay then square brackets we're gonna
write one and it will
pick the ice like this okay control s
and then um we have also set it to one
second okay so we're gonna get it after
one second clear the console
save it right let's count one
two again one two
one now you can see that we got this
after two seconds we got this
immediately we got it after two seconds
and an additional one second later we
got water and
ice was added which means that our
function is running properly
now we're gonna start the machine it
will take one second okay
um inside this okay stocks
dot liquid i mean where we have selected
the water and ice
okay so inside over here um
we're gonna write set timeout okay okay
then the arrow function over here curly
braces and over here we're gonna write
what
the time function okay 1000 seconds like
this
and inside here we're gonna write
console.log and then we're gonna write
the machine
was started let's write the machine has
been started
the machine has
been let's write the machine was started
okay control s let's complete all of our
steps and then run it together okay
the next step is we need to select the
container okay
now if you come over to the stocks you
can see that on the holder object we
have a lot of options we have the
cone the cup and the stick let's pick
the cup
no i changed my mind let's pick the cone
okay in order to do that
you come over here okay where the
machine was started okay
and at the bottom over here we're gonna
write the set timeout
so the cup takes um two seconds okay
so you're gonna write set timeout like
this okay
keep some space otherwise you're gonna
get confused by yourself
okay set timeout and then brackets
then over here you're gonna give that
arrow sign
i mean the arrow function and then
you're gonna set it oh sorry
uh this time over here okay two seconds
and then inside over here we're gonna
write console.log
we have picked which one the code right
let's see that where is the cone holder
okay
stocks dot holder dot zero
okay let's write it over here okay don't
get confused it is over here
below the machine okay we're gonna give
what
backticks that's because we are trying
to get something
outside the function okay so dollar sign
curly braces stocks s t o c k s
stocks dot which one was that holder
h o l d e r that's because this is the
holder over here okay
stocks dot holder and then zero
let's come back over here then we're
gonna give
um square brackets like this and then
we're gonna write zero over here and
then we're done
what's the next step the next step is
we're gonna select the topping ah my
favorite
i love chocolates what about you comment
down below
do you like waffles chocolates or
peanuts
okay then um where was i oh yes we're
gonna select what chocolates okay as the
toppings look
stocks dot toppings we have that s don't
forget that okay
and then we're gonna pick the zero you
can also pick peanuts also as well
in order to pick that peanut you're
gonna write one okay stocks dot toppings
dot
one okay um over here okay
this is the holder oh i forgot to write
okay
which means that the cup was i mean the
cone was
selected okay selected
or you can also write ice cream was
placed on
the cone okay come over here and write
ice cream
was placed on what
the ice cream was placed on this one
which means
on the cone ice cream was placed on cone
all right so inside over here uh give
some spacings
and we're gonna pick what the topping it
takes three seconds
because you need some time to melt the
chocolate right
so over here you write uh set timeout
okay it's gonna take
an arrow function like this and then
it's gonna take three
oh sorry three seconds okay so what are
we gonna do we're gonna pick
toppings so console but log like this
and um backpicks okay don't forget that
backticks like this dollar sign curly
braces and what we're gonna write
uh stocks stocks dot
toppings we have that s at the last
toppings and then this square brackets
then write zero control s and what's the
last step
we're gonna serve the ice cream okay so
you have to serve the ice cream come
over here okay
where we have written this oh this is
just plain chocolate i forgot to write
more text okay so stocks dot toppings
which is the chocolate
was added okay as toppings
like this okay and over here give some
spacing write another set timeout
function okay
set timeout and over here um
we're gonna place an error function like
this
and then we're gonna set the time which
takes how many seconds to serve
two seconds okay two one two three
console.log
uh then double quotes
serve ice cream
ctrl s okay now clear the console over
here
so now run the code let's see what
happens
okay strawberry was selected production
has started
fruit has been chopped water and ice
added the machine was started
ice cream was placed on cone chocolate
was added as toppings
then we're gonna serve the ice cream
then we're gonna take the money and buy
ourselves a lambo
yay party okay now we have
complete our process the callbacks
but look at look at this what have we
created let me expand this and let me
show you what we have created it is
called a callback hell
look at here look look at this format of
how it is going
okay look look look look like this and
then it is ending like this this is
called a callback hell
what is it called callback hell let me
show you the format
the callback hell looks something like
this look at this format over here
and look at our code over here it looks
similar it looks like this look
it looks like a christmas tree
you can also call it the christmas tree
of hell because why not
i know i know i know that callbacks are
very confusing
and it is a hell so what's the solution
of callbacks
we have promises and promises looks like
this look
this is the promises it looks very clean
very neat so let's compare again
this is our callback hell and this is
our
promises look how clean it looks
the thing works like this callbacks make
relationships
parent children grandchildren grand
grandchildren
grand grand grandchildren grand grand
grand grandchildren
it forms relationship like this so what
but what promises do is it takes
instructions like this
first do this then this then this then
this
then then then it works like this which
means that you can
keep your code very neat and clean so
far so good
let's start discussing our promises in
order to understand the promise
first of all you need to understand the
promise cycle
so this is the diagram i made about the
promise cycle
first of all a promise is made what
promise do we make to our customers
sir we promise that we are gonna serve
you ice cream
what ice cream we promise we're gonna
serve you ice cream
so there are two parts of this promise
either it will be fulfilled
or it will get rejected okay so here
first of all it comes to this stage the
pending stage
every customer when they come into our
shop we promise
we're gonna serve you ice cream so our
customer enters our shop
sits on the table looks at the menu and
he or she didn't order anything
he's just sitting over there so this
stage is called the pending stage
he didn't order anything just sitting
over there so this is the pending stage
nothing is happening
we didn't take the order we didn't start
the production
okay and now let's say that
the customer has placed an order he
wants mango ice cream
if we have the mango on our stock
then we can go to the next stage which
is we can resolve the promise
which means that we can serve ice cream
to our customer but
if we don't have the mango then what
will happen is we have to reject it
by saying sir we don't have mango at our
stocks we are very sorry
so let's say that we have mango on our
stocks what will happen is
it's gonna get resolved first of all and
then after that what will happen is
we have seven steps to make ice cream
right yes or no we have seven steps to
make ice cream
and it will follow like this first of
all do this
then this then this then this
like this in total there are seven thens
or six dens
depending on the circumstances depending
on the situation don't worry we're gonna
write code
and see how this thing works once that's
done we can serve ice cream to our
customers
but let's say that we don't have mango
what will happen is we have to pass
through this reject stage
and then over here on this catch we're
gonna write a
sorry note we're gonna say sir we're
very sorry we don't have this on our
stock
we sincerely apologize for the
inconvenience
and once either we get resolved
either our promise gets resolved or
rejected
this finally will always run let's say
that we
serve zero customers at the end of the
day we have to close our shutters i mean
we have to close our
shop but let's say that at the end of
the day we
served 100 customers 100 customers
we still have to close our shop right
because the employees has to leave
we have to leave this is the final
handler don't worry we're going to
discuss all of them in details
once you have understood this promise
cycle we need to understand four more
things
don't worry this is very short first of
all we need to understand the
relationship between two things
time and work what time and
work because we have this list over here
you can see that first of all
we have the work and then the time
that's why those two relationships
the next thing is the promise chaining
what promise chaining is
um if you come over here you can see
that we are doing all the steps through
then then then then this is the promise
chaining okay
so first of all we get resolved okay and
then it comes over here
then we return it first of all resolve
then
return return return return like that
don't worry we're gonna write code and
explain
and i'm gonna explain that to you all
right so this is the promise changing
the error handling part
is this one look this catch handler is
the error handling part
when we have a reject all right and the
final handler i told you earlier right
this is the final handler is gonna run
whether we serve zero or hundred
customers
i mean whether our promise gets resolved
or rejected
all right then come to your code editor
over here delete everything
except your stocks variable
over here and you clear the console over
here okay now the first thing is
the absolute first thing is we're gonna
create a variable
named is shop open follow me
let is underscore shop
underscore open okay equal to true
so what this is holding is we are asking
the question is our shop open or
closed if it is true we are serving ice
cream
if it is closed we're sorry sir we are
closed okay
now we're gonna create a function an
arrow function
with the name order like this let
order equal to brackets over here then
equal
to arrow function now what we're going
to do is
do you remember the relationship between
time and work that i told you earlier
we're going to write time and work over
here okay
time over here and work over here you
can also
shift the positions you can write work
first and then
time it totally depends on you and the
next thing is we're gonna make a promise
first we made the order then we made the
promise
sir we're gonna serve you ice cream like
this
follow me first of all you're gonna
write return
okay new then capital letter p
what capital letter p p r o
m i s e promise like this look then
brackets
give a little bit of space so that you
can understand what we are writing okay
over here we're gonna give brackets over
here again
we're gonna create a arrow function look
like this okay
like this we've made a arrow function
over here now press
enter now um
inside this brackets we're gonna pass
two arguments
resolve reject which means that we have
how many stage
three stages pending resolve reject
we're gonna write
resolve reject we don't need the pending
okay
now right resolve like this resolve like
this and over here you're gonna write
reject reject like this okay
so we made a promise now it's time to
run that promise okay
now we have two stages resolve and
reject
let's write an if else statement
so right um if is
shop open which means that if our shop
is open
then we are gonna resolve it like this
resolve
which means that we're gonna serve ice
cream
that our shop is open welcome sir we're
gonna serve you ice cream
how are we gonna serve our ice cream
we're gonna write this
work you see this work over here we're
gonna write this work over here
like this look we passed the work over
here which means that
when the shop is open when our customer
came we're gonna say sir we promise that
we're gonna serve you ice cream
as long as we have all the stocks and
the raw materials then we're gonna start
working
all right now if our shop is closed then
what will happen we're going to write an
else statement over here okay curly
braces and over here we're going to
write what
reject reject like this and
you close it like this i mean the
brackets and over here you write
console oh sorry
console.log like this okay
and over here we're gonna write our oh
sorry
our shop is closed okay
like this so far so good now you can see
that we have formed relationship between
with just
work look this work is over here but we
also need to form relationship between
time also along with work
so what will we use we're going to use a
set timeout function
so that we can form the relationship
between our time
and work follow along with me okay so
below this if statement write set
timeout okay
and then brackets over here form a
arrow function like this look okay
error function like this and then what
you're gonna do is you're gonna put a
comma over here
comma we're gonna pass this time
function i mean the time word over here
which means that every time we need to
write
the order function we're gonna place the
time and the work
don't worry we're gonna write it and
then what you're gonna do is you're
gonna
cut this result from here ctrl x
okay and then you're gonna paste it
inside this arrow function
now what will happen is it's gonna form
a serial
after one two three four five
six seven we have draw seven steps now
save this code let's test it
okay so what is the name of our function
it's order okay
so come at the very bottom over here you
write order
okay now brackets now look at the first
thing what is it
first thing is the time and then the
work
so how you are gonna define this follow
along with me
the first thing is time okay so let's
look at the chart
so this is our chart which carries all
the steps first thing is we need to
place the order okay it's gonna take two
seconds
in order to write that first of all
we're gonna give the time okay
you're gonna write two seconds like this
two one two three two thousand
milliseconds and then
a comma comma like this and now we're
going to create a small arrow function
look at this okay and then the arrow
sign
if you write the statement in a single
line you don't have to put this curly
braces
you can just use directly like this
console.log
okay first of all we're gonna select the
fruit in order to select the fruit what
do you need
backticks what backticks like this okay
then dollar sign curly braces like this
so
what's the name of our stocks this one
okay
stocks dot fruit uh let me check
fruits yes stocks dot
fruits like this and then we're gonna
pick the strawberry okay
zero this hand uh
square brackets and then zero like this
now let's test it
ctrl s and then um
clear the console save it and
run it like this after two seconds we're
gonna get the result
one two there we go we have strawberry
over here
now let's complete this by saying that
strawberry
was selected okay
ctrl s click the console
run it one two there we go
we have our strawberry was selected i
hope you understood the relationship
between the time and work function this
was pretty simple
now let's start discussing about the
promise chaining
which is this one over here the then
then then
then part first you have to do this then
this
then this etc let's come back to the vs
code over here and at the very bottom
if you want to work with the promise
chaining you cannot have
anything between the first call of the
order
and then your then handler like this if
you want to
do promise chaining you have to do this
dot then okay
then dot then
dot then so on and so forth
oh i made a spelling mistake my bad then
you cannot have this semicolon over here
okay so just remove the semicolon from
there
okay now it's going to work perfectly
fine you can have
100 lines of spaces like this and it's
still going to work
like this but for this tutorial i'm
going to have just two spaces so that
it can look very good and tidy
okay so like this look at that
it looks quite good and now in order to
write i mean in order to give an
instruction inside that then
let's look at our chart so this is the
chart
which carries the steps what is the next
step we need to cut the fruit
and it's gonna take two seconds okay now
come back to coat pan and over here
before cutting the fruit let's give a
call to start the production how do we
do this
first of all write an arrow function
like this look
okay arrow sign you can also write it in
a single line but
i'm gonna give curly braces over here
and then you're gonna return it you have
to return it otherwise it's not gonna
work
the first part is resolve then
return return return return return
so on and so forth if you don't write
the return over there then it's not
gonna work okay
follow along with me you write return
over here okay
then order what was that order the name
of our function okay
like this look and then you're gonna
place what time
first in order to start the production
it takes zero second
zero zero zero 0 comma
and then you're going to write a
function over here okay
arrow function like this console.log
like this and then we're going to write
over here production has started
production has sorry
started okay save it
and then we're gonna clear the console
let's run it
so we're gonna get this one after two
seconds and this one
immediately one two there is our
strawberry was selected
and production has started it took two
seconds and this one took just
zero seconds okay now let's write the
next step what was the next step we need
to chop
the food it takes two seconds i mean cut
the food
okay let's follow the same process okay
over here you're gonna write an arrow
function
like this equal to then this
arrow side curly braces right over here
what
return what was it return
return like this okay order
we're gonna write uh 2000 over here
which means two seconds
okay equal to like this then console.log
um what was it we're gonna cut the fruit
okay
the fruit was chopped
sorry ctrl
s okay there we go
following this chart let's complete our
process okay next is
we have to add water and ice let's go
and do it so over here
we're gonna follow the same process
let's actually um
copy this code from here okay now look
let's not copy the code okay let's just
do it manually so that you can learn it
okay follow along with me arrow function
over here okay
return um return
order um it's gonna take how many
seconds
one second okay one one two three okay
then this sign which is um
the arrow function give a curly braces
over here okay
and inside over here and write
console.log
um what was it backticks okay
then dollar sign curly braces that is
because we need to
select what our liquid which is water
and ice
okay stocks dot liquid come at the very
bottom over here we write
stocks dot liquid like this
and then zero in order to select what
the water
okay and over here right and
again you write dollar sign curly braces
stocks
dot liquid and then what was it
one okay so water and ice was
selected like this there we go
and remember this this is very crucial
you cannot have
semicolons between tens okay remove this
semicolon from here i mistakenly
wrote it okay space and over here we're
gonna write
10 brackets
arrow sign like this curly braces what's
the next step
let's see we need to start the machine
in one second okay
so right return sorry
return order
square bracket then
first of all you need to write the time
okay one
seconds like this air sign
like this console dot log
um start the
machine like this
next step is we need to select the
container we're going to select the cone
okay
in order to do that come here dot 10
okay then arrow function like this
return order it takes how many seconds
two seconds to select the cone okay
sorry my bad oh
then the arrow function over here curly
braces inside you're gonna write
console a log um what was it
um backticks okay then dollar sign
curly braces over here you're gonna
write stocks
dot which was it let's see top and a
holder
holder and then zero because the cone is
over here okay
at the very bottom holder h l d e r
like this square bracket zero
okay then you're gonna write uh was
uh ice cream was placed on this holder
okay so
ice cream placed
on it translates to ice cream
placed on cone okay next step is
select toppings we're gonna pick
chocolate dot 10 okay
then this sign i mean the arrow function
return sorry return
order uh three seconds because
chocolate takes time to melt right so
equal to
uh arrow function then console
the log then inside over here backticks
okay when
backticks okay don't forget dollar sign
curly braces over here you write stocks
dot toppings i n g
s don't forget the last s top pinks
and then square brackets over here we're
gonna write zero
chocolate was selected
like this so we're almost done then
we're gonna serve the ice cream
serve ice cream we're gonna write um dot
10
okay like this um
return order
you're gonna write how many seconds it's
gonna take it's gonna take two seconds
okay
equal to curly braces uh we don't need
curly braces actually we can write it
directly okay one
two three like this uh
like this equal to this sign the
arrow function and then console.log
okay double quotes ice cream
was served ctrl
there we go we completed our process now
let's run our code before that
clear this console run it let's go
strawberry are selected production has
started the fruit was chopped
water and ice added start the machine
ice cream place on cone
then where is our chocolate there is our
chocolate chocolate was selected
ice cream was served give us the money
and let us buy us the lambo yay
now is now it's time to understand the
error handling part okay
which is this one over here the catch
handler in order to understand the catch
handler come at the very bottom over
here okay
and you're right uh oh don't forget to
remove this semicolon from here
otherwise it's not gonna
work you write dot catch like this okay
like this then write an arrow function
like this okay
equal to curly braces like this and over
here right
console the log customer
left
like this ctrl s and then clear the
console now this catch will
only work when our promise is rejected i
mean
when we cannot serve ice cream to our
customers
then this catch then this catch will
work let me show you okay
if you can read if you can remember this
variable at the very top over here below
the stock
which is is shop open it is true
let's convert it to false and let's see
what will happen
theoretically theoretically then we're
gonna run this code okay
let's see we have this if statement over
here
it will run when the variable is true
but it is false which means our shop is
closed look at here else reject our shop
is
closed so false and then
this this code will be run
first and then at the very bottom we
have this sketch
then this line of code will run and
these things will not run this all then
then then it will not run
let's do a test run it and let's see
what happens okay so our shop is closed
the first thing we're gonna get is our
shop is closed look
at this message over here inside this
reject statement
look our shop is closed and then at the
very bottom look at this
this catch handler customer left we're
very sorry
this left they left us look the customer
left
we're not gonna make the money we can't
buy the lambo we're very sorry
all right then i hope you understood
this catch i mean the error handling
part with the catch handler
let's understand this finally handler i
told you earlier that
is this will run whether our promise is
resolved or rejected
it will run anyways okay now let's look
at this example but first
remove this semicolon otherwise it's not
gonna work okay then dot
finally like this and inside over here
we're gonna write what
tell me arrow function okay like this
equal to this sign
curly braces like this we're gonna write
console.log
like this and inside over here we're
gonna write our shop
is closed now let's write day ended
shop is closed okay day ended
shop is closed like this okay
let's save it do you remember what state
is it in our shop is
closed which is false okay let's run it
in this way you can also run it in true
let's see look our shop is closed this
message is coming from this
reject statement over here customer left
is coming from this statement over here
this catch handler
okay and this day ended chop is closed
it's coming from this finally handler
let's set it to true and let's see what
will actually happen with our
finally handler okay control s run it
uh clear the console and let's see what
happens
okay we got this statement then this
then water and ice added
then this um ice cream place in cone
then my favorite part is the chocolate
yay
and then ice cream was served day ended
shop is closed look at this look look
at the very end they ended shop is
closed is coming from this
finally handler so what do you
understand it will run whether our
promise is resolved or rejected
and with that we finished our discussion
with promises
everyone please welcome async await yay
so this is actually proclaimed to be a
better way to write
promises let's go and dissect async
await
but first you take a break because you
really deserve a break
in order to understand the async await
first of all you need to know the
difference between the promises
and the async await let's look at an
example
come back to vs code i mean codepen you
delete everything except
our um this part okay
keep the shop and the stocks okay
now in the promises part how did we make
a promise like this look
function uh let's name it order okay
order like this okay now we actually
didn't write it like this
my bad we wrote it in the arrowway
function i mean the arrow function so
left order equal to
this equal to um arrow sign
curly braces like this and in order to
make the promise we wrote what
return new promise return
new oh my bad new capital letter p
r o m i s c promise like this and then
inside this brackets we wrote
another um arrow function like this okay
and instead here we wrote resolve
recheck like this okay
and then inside over here what we wrote
if statement okay then this one and
inside over here what did we
all right what did we write we wrote the
results like this okay
look at this and over the else statement
what did we write okay
we wrote the reject over here oh my bad
we checked like this okay we wrote it
like this
this was the promise but how do we write
the async await
look at this look look right first of
all the async
keyword what the async keyword
is sync okay you write the function
order okay this and then the curly
braces and there we go we made ourselves
a promise
how simple is that but wait the story
doesn't end here we need to understand
two more things
the try catch handler and how to use the
await keyword
so this is the async keyword we need to
understand the await keyword
let's dive in now let's come back to our
code pan
and understand the difference between
the promise
and our async await only then we can
understand that try
catch okay come over here and see
this if an else statement what did we
write
how did we make the promise we made this
promise like this first of all we wrote
the function over here
and then return new promise then resolve
reject and then we wrote the if
statement which is
if this is true we wrote this t-r-u-e
true okay
then it's gonna resolve it if it's not
true then it's gonna reject it like this
this is how we make the promise and then
what did we do okay
we comment this like this let me
actually finish with the promise part
then we're gonna come to the async
javascript part i mean async await part
this is the order right how did we write
it order
okay order this is our first start and
then what did you write
dot then okay dot then
dot then oh sorry
my bad and then what did we write and
then we wrote
dot catch catch t
c c a t c oh i forgot my bad
c a t c h catch handler and then the dot
finally handler okay so this
will work when what if our promise was
resolved
this will work when it is rejected this
will work anyways it's still gonna work
even if it was
resolved or rejected but in terms of
this
um async await let's actually test it
with this how this works okay
don't worry about this one let's comment
this
we're gonna return over here okay don't
worry comment this like this
and come over here so first thing is you
know if you want to declare
i mean if you want to work with promises
in the async await
world then what we have to do is we have
to declare this async
word before the function i showed you a
little while ago right
and then inside over here you have three
options i mean
three things to write try catch and
finally what tell me try catch
finally over here we wrote what the if
else statement
and over here we're gonna write try
catch finally
follow me you're right try over here
okay curly braces like this
and then you're gonna write the catch
okay and
brackets over here you write error okay
curly braces and over here you write
finally like this okay then curly braces
so what does this finally does it it
runs quotes anyways okay let's write it
okay
don't worry we're gonna test it okay
console.log
um runs code any
ways okay inside this catch handler i
mean let's start with the try okay
let's create a fake problem what problem
fake
problem over here we're gonna write away
don't worry about the avoid keyword i'm
gonna discuss
in detail about this await keyword okay
it's coming
wait you write away
so this abc is actually pointing out to
a function which
doesn't exist and i still wrote it
because it's a
fake function what function fake
function okay
so inside this catch handler what we're
gonna write is
console the log like this and over here
we're gonna write
abc doesn't exist
exist okay and this error is actually
written like this
comma error okay
for now we don't need this error part
but we're just keeping it over here as
it is
we just want to work with our try catch
this console log and this final error
and this finally handler in order to
understand the main theory of the async
await okay
so you clear the console here as i told
you earlier
this 808 abc i mean this abc part
doesn't exist look at the
entire code field nothing exists which
is named abc
right so in order to run this first of
all you need to
provoke it like by saying order at the
very bottom over here right order okay
oh my bad sorry like this ctrl s
and let's run it and let's see what
happens
there we go we got the message first of
all avc doesn't exist
because we don't have anything named avc
then um
it then we have runs code anyways
look at this the finally handler do you
remember this finally from the promises
this is over here it will run code
anyways
by the way do you remember this handlers
this then
catch finally handlers you can also use
them inside i mean outside the
async await system as well let me show
you a demo okay
you right at the bottom of the order
after removing that semicolon
but then like this okay brackets then
create
a error function like this and over here
you write
console dot log
then write anything you wish i'm gonna
write like this my bad
am i bad i don't i cannot think anything
of good right now
ctrl s clear this run it like this
ah there we go we have got that then
handler
it is printing over here okay first of
all we got that error
and then the finally it's gonna run
anyways okay so that is over here
and then the then what will happen after
our promise is
resolve it's gonna do this part over
here
and you can also use those then catch
finally
etc after here it is the chaining part
okay
i hope you understood this far now let's
do a small test and understand the await
keyword
let's say that i am the chef of the
restaurant okay just look at me
i am the chef of the restaurant okay i
make ice cream i took
the order from the customer and i'm
making ice cream okay
my bad sorry okay so i'm making ice
cream over here but i then realized that
my customer didn't tell me which topping
would he like so i have to go
outside the kitchen ask the customer sir
which stuffing topping would you like
chocolate or peanut
then he's gonna give me the order give
me chocolate
and then i have to return to the kitchen
and start working look how the process
is working i am going outside which
means that the kitchen is being stocked
completely without the chef the kitchen
doesn't work
but realize this that there are other
employees at the restaurant who is
working who is cleaning the
tables cleaning the dishes taking orders
etc everything else except the kitchen
is working
this is where we use the await keyword
let's do a
test and understand about this await
keyword
in details let's start
now come back to codepen now come back
to codepen and remove everything
except the stocks and the east shop open
okay
remove everything like this goodbye
forever
okay now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna create a function what
a function which one arrow function okay
let let's write toppings choice
okay
which will ask the customer sir which
topic would you love
okay equal to my bad equal to
brackets this sign which is the arrow
sign and inside over here we're going to
make a new promise what
new promise okay so return
new promise like this
and over here we're gonna write resolve
reject don't worry i'm coming on the
async await part okay
so equal to arrow sign
curly braces and over here what we're
gonna write come on tell me
resolve reject resolve
way like that recheck like this okay
now over here what are we gonna do we're
gonna create a set timeout
let's say that the asking process takes
how many seconds three seconds how many
three seconds okay in order to do that
you're gonna write set timeout okay
for three seconds so write set
timeout like this okay and then what we
have to write is come on tell me
arrow function okay like this
and then we're gonna set the time how
many seconds three seconds three
one two three all right now inside over
here we're gonna write console.log
console.log over here we're gonna write
which toppings
[Music]
oh my bad like this remove this console
from here
clear okay control s now we made a small
promise that we have to go
outside the kitchen ask our customer
what would he love to have
as a topping now at the very bottom what
we're going to create is this function
async function
a sync function um we're going to write
what
brackets oh we also have to give it a
name we're gonna name it
kitchen k i t c h e n kitchen over here
and then curly braces over here like
this
now follow along with me we're gonna
write console.log
five times a b c d e like this okay
console.log okay like this
ctrl c one oh my bad
two three four five okay now
we can write over here a don't worry i'm
going to explain that why i wrote abcd
of my bad b
e okay now what we're gonna do is oh let
me actually explain why i wrote this
abcde
and all this part okay the thing is
these are the steps we are working
with i mean we are working at the
kitchen okay we are making ice cream we
are following the steps one two three
four and the very middle we just
realized which topping would our
customer love okay so we have to go
outside the kitchen what outside the
kitchen
ask him sir what did you love to have so
this is our kitchen we're inside over
here
where where we're inside this kitchen
we're working
now we need to go outside and come to
this toppings
choice which is the where the customer
is sitting ask him
sir what would you love to have and then
once we have got the data
we're gonna come back to our kitchen
start working and then
serve him in the meantime what will
happen others
other works like cleaning the dishes
cleaning the table
taking other customers orders will keep
running don't worry i'm coming to that
part okay
now what you're gonna write is at the
very middle over here you're gonna write
a weight then what the name of this
function what is this toppings
choice ctrl c that one ctrl v
and then brackets close it and then
what we're going to do is in order to
provoke this function we're going to
come over at the very bottom over here
you're gonna write
kitchen what kitchen kitchen like this
okay
and then we're gonna define other tasks
which is happening
except myself i'm the what i'm the chef
okay
other words are what cooking i mean
sorry cleaning the dishes
cleaning the table taking other orders
let's write them okay
console the log um
cleaning my bad
ceiling the dishes console the log like
this con
i mean this one ctrl c ctrl c
then what cleaning the tables
actually you're right doing the dishes
it sounds
good i guess doing the dishes
dishes cleaning the table and then at
the bottom we're gonna write
taking others order
like this okay ctrl s now let me
theoretically explain you before running
the run
button that what is actually happening
okay so look i'm working over here okay
i'm making the
ice cream and then i realized that i
don't have the
necessary direction which topping would
my customer love so i'm
physically going outside the kitchen to
ask the customer
what would you love to have which means
that this entire process
is stopped my kitchen is stopped nothing
is happening because the chef is outside
and in the meantime other work like this
one
will still happen like doing the dishes
cleaning the table
taking others orders and once i return
to the kitchen these two work
d and e will work let's run it and let's
test what will happen
okay look a b c
doing the dishes cleaning the table
taking other swatters
which topping would you love oh we
didn't actually get the d
and e that's because i actually forgot
something
i forgot to write the resolve over here
and without writing the result
it's not going to return our other tasks
okay so come over here on the toppings
choice okay or and inside over here
you're going to write
results like this bracket
and inside the brackets we're gonna
place this console over here okay
control x my apologies i actually forgot
to write that part
and control s okay now clear this and
run the code and let's see what actually
happens okay
oh i actually have an error i don't know
why but let's check it out
okay console or log
which topping
do us my bad
like okay like this ctrl s let's see
what happens right now clear the console
like this
now you can see that we have fixed our
error over here we have written the
result over here
and we have replaced the console.log
inside this
line over here now it's gonna work
perfectly fine let's run the code and
see what happens
um there we go we have abc
doing the dishes cleaning the tables
taking others orders
which topping do you like and then we
have other works
what is happening let me explain again
so what is happening look here
in the kitchen i am working in the
kitchen where am i working in the
kitchen
so these three tasks are done then i
remember
what topping does my customer likes so
i'm going outside
and asking him in the meantime others
are working look
other people are working over here if
there was 100 tasks
they would have they would have been
working on those tasks
okay so once these stacks are done
in the meantime what i have done is i
have gone to the customer asked him
took the data returned to the kitchen
and i started working then d
and e is completed on this bottom over
here you can see that
i hope you understood the await keyword
i hope you understood the resolve
keyword let's reopen our shop and
welcome customers
okay now come back to codepen delete
everything except this one
and this one okay like this follow along
with me
delete goodbye and over here what we're
gonna write is
first of all a time function because we
need to
set the relationship between time and
work right
so you write um function
okay time and right over here ms which
means milliseconds okay
curly braces like this we're gonna
create a new promise okay
return new
promise don't worry about the async
await i'm coming to that part okay
capital letter p not small letter p r o
and my se and then inside over here
you're gonna write
um the resolve and reject part resolve
um and the reject part you check like
this
and the arrow function my bad arrow
function over here like this and then
the if and else statement like this
if our shop is open is shop open
look at this is shop open and then we're
gonna write what
we're gonna create set timeout remember
this
set timeout like this and over here
we are forming a relationship between
our time and work
okay so inside here we're going to write
the result we are passing this resolve
over here which means that
we're setting the relationship between
the time and work okay
so resolve over here and then that
ms part should be over here ms like this
and on the else statement els
statement so what this will do is
it will notify us when our shop is
closed i mean when
is shop open set to false okay like that
so we're going to write reject like this
instead over here we're going to write
console console
dot log like this and um we're gonna
write
shop my bad is closed
ctrl s now we're going to write a async
function named kitchen to start our
production inside there
okay come at the very bottom oh before
that you clean the console because it
looks quite dirty
okay so now you're going to write async
like this
function create the kitchen okay
okay i-t-c-h-e-n kitchen like this curly
braces
like this over here and then we're gonna
write
try okay like this then
catch like this and if you want you can
also write the finally
that's completely up to you but i'm
gonna write it because a lot of you
don't
really understand how to work with the
try catch and finally i'm gonna explain
everything in details don't worry about
it okay
and over here i actually forgot to write
brackets and error
like this all right and now in order to
run this
what we have to write is at the very
bottom we're gonna write the kitchen
which is the trigger
kitchen like this okay ctrl s
now let's actually test our function to
check whether if it's
working or not so come on in this um
catch handler
and we're going to write um console.log
like this um we're gonna write customer
left okay
customer left like this and over here
we're gonna write
error like this and inside over here
what we're gonna write
is shop is closed okay console.log
day ended shop is
closed okay now what are we gonna write
inside this
try handler let's see okay one by one
if you remember this chart the first
thing that we need to pick is the order
i mean
the fruit name okay so come back to our
code pane over here and
we're gonna write console.log
and then backticks don't forget that
dollar sign curly braces like this and
then we're gonna write
stocks like this stocks dot fruits
f-r-u-i-t-s
and then we're gonna pick the strawberry
zero or you can pick anything you wish
from this list of stocks okay you can
pick grades banana etc
all right now what we're gonna do is if
you remember this we have two seconds of
time
how are we gonna define the two seconds
over here
in order to define the two seconds do
you remember this function over here
the time function we're gonna utilize
this look at here
look we're gonna write a weight and then
what
the name of this function time okay time
over here
and then we're gonna set it to how many
seconds two seconds
two one two three two thousand
milliseconds means two seconds
now let's test the code okay as our shop
is open
now it's gonna give us what resolve look
at this
it's gonna get resolved okay let's run
the code
and see what happens so after two
seconds we're gonna get this strawberry
over here that's because we have set it
to two seconds
and they ended shop close will be
printed immediately because we didn't
assign any time over here
so it is assured that that function
works and there is no problem in our
function
let's complete our ice cream production
business
following these steps over here okay now
what you're gonna do is
come over here you press enter enter i
mean keep some space between your code
so that it looks neat and clean
and then we're gonna write console.log
um start the production okay
start the production it's not gonna take
any time
okay we can keep it blank for now but if
you want
to learn but if you want you can keep
a weight time zero zero zero zero it's
completely up to you
but for making you understand how the
system works we're gonna keep it zero
zero zero zero so that you can know that
this thing takes zero seconds to start
okay
now we're gonna start um we're gonna cut
the fruit okay
so console.log
um cut the fruit like this
and it's gonna take how many seconds two
seconds away
time to one two three i mean two seconds
okay
then we have the add water and ice
it's gonna take one second let's go boys
and girls
oh my bad i wrote the wrong thing away
term is gonna take one two three like
this
console.log
and we're gonna write what water and ice
backticks dollar sign curly braces
and dollar sign curly braces
was added like this and over here we're
gonna write
pick the water so stocks dot
liquid square brackets zero
okay stocks dot
liquid then we're gonna write one there
we go
and over here we're gonna start the
machine in one second select the
container two second
so how do we do this um we can also copy
this no worries
like this okay ctrl v first we need what
one second to start the machine and then
two seconds to select the container so
one second is over here
and the two second part is over here
okay two second part is here
and let's actually complete it all
together so topping sparse takes three
seconds
to serve ice cream which takes two
seconds okay so let's do it like this
so this is our three seconds over here
this is our serving over here okay two
seconds
now we're gonna write um start the
machine okay
so console.log
start the machine like this
and then console the log
it will be our um select the container
okay
backticks dollar sign curly braces
stocks dot holder
zero it will pick the cone okay ice
cream placed on cone
ice cream placed on
cone like this okay now consolidate log
console a dot log
like this um do we need backticks yes
because we need to pick the toppings
chocolate
tactics dollar sign curly braces
uh stocks dot uh
toppings e-o-p i-n-g-s then
zero which will pick the chocolate was
selected at the very last what we're
gonna write is we're gonna serve ice
cream
take the money and buy ourselves a lambo
because why not come on boys and girls
console.log okay
serve ice cream
let's save our code clear our console um
like this and let's run run it and see
what happens
maintaining time everything will run
strawberry oh actually
forgot to write strawberry was selected
my bag
was selected okay clear this console
save it run it again sequentially
maintaining time it will run look
strawberry was selected
start the production cut the food then
this start the machine
ice cream placed on cone then after
three seconds we will have chocolate was
selected
server ice cream they ended shop is
closed but what will happen if we have
uh false over here let's see okay false
which means that it's gonna reject it
look at here reject console.log shop is
closed which means that
this else this is reject this thing will
come
i mean this thing will be printed first
and then
look at this sketch over here catch
error
customer left and then the finally day
ended shop is closed
let's test it look at that
shop is closed customer left they ended
shop is closed
this is coming from where let me show
you this is coming from this else this
reject from the time
function customer left it is coming from
where
look at this is from coming from the
catch and they
end up shop is closed this will run
anyways it is coming from this finally
handler
so we successfully made ice cream today
and along with that we have completed
our tutorial
if you like the video give a like share
it with a friend and feel free to
subscribe
till then take care and i'll see in the
next video bye bye